[Music]
all right john
you know about tick-tock
um i've got several of them on the wall
in my house oh boy okay this is going to
take a while guys buckle in so tick-tock
is a social media platform i know what
it is it's blown up in popularity among
the youth and now among the olds yeah
that's what they call it they call them
the olds yes
i'm learning from gen z i'm learning and
so here's the deal this radio show is
mostly geared towards the olds if you've
heard about tick tock you know oh isn't
that just like weird dance challenges it
has become so much more and so there's a
lot of
personal finance tick talkers out there
creating content to help the people yeah
i've seen the uh some of the uh personal
physical fitness and mental health
advice
that uh that's what shows up on your
feed some of the tick talkers are
bestowing upon us all yeah and it's a
it's a lot of 17 year olds with opinions
about how you should handle your money
talks and i know everything you're a
genius i'm a genius so i i stumble upon
videos all the time that just cause me
to be very angry very instantly because
it's just a cesspool of terrible
financial advice
that is
just helping gen z go into debt faster
ah because that's how to set up the
youth of america for their adult life
thanks tiktok and so as i come across
them i thought why don't we play one on
the show for all of america to hear okay
let me set this up this is a girl who is
playing two characters same person two
characters it's going back and forth and
it's she's the mom and she's the
daughter but talking to herself in a
very clever way yes i know i love
cleveland the mom is anti-credit card
and the daughter is explaining to mom
why she's a why she's a genius and you
should have a credit card so let's play
the clip and let's see your reaction mom
i'm ready for my first credit card
absolutely not credit cards are evil
honey no they're not do you even know
how they work yeah it's literally a card
with money on it the money belongs to a
bank and every time i use the card to
buy something i'm borrowing their money
to pay for it see you're using their
money this is going to get you into a
lot of debt no it
can get me into debt if i use it
irresponsibly but i won't let that
happen how are you gonna manage that
when the bill comes each month i have
the option to pay the minimum amount or
the entire amount that i borrowed if i
pay the full amount every month then
i'll never owe any interest or get into
debt and what if you forget to pay i
won't spend more money than i have and
i'll turn on autopay so it will
automatically pay off the entire balance
every month fine but why not just use
your debit card if you have the money
anyways they reward you with things like
cash back or free travel plus it builds
your credit score okay it looks like you
know your stuff how did you learn all
this madison taught me she teaches all
the money hacks that's why i follow her
i literally want to set my own hair on
fire john
i can't breathe just to to see if i can
still feel
what is way to go america i think i held
my breath during that whole video i'm
just now realizing yeah you should
breathe during times of stress you have
experience with breathing exercises that
is right so okay there's a lot to unpack
here john um there's like there's very
little to unpack
you're right but i just need to say it
because it needs to be said
that advice
is one of the many reasons and let me
tell you that video millions of views
really half a million likes wow
this is what the younger generations are
clinging to going yes finally someone
who gets it because my mom was just
telling me the same thing dumbledore i'm
like mom you don't understand i'm gonna
pay it off every month
and so it just brings me to this point
will smith already sang that song
parents just don't understand we've
we've dealt with the credit card issue
time and time again but let me just
reiterate why
that advice is going to cause a lot of
harm to your life number one
we get a lot of debt-free screams that
come through this lobby we've had 72 so
far this year that have paid off over 10
and a half million dollars total
you know how they went into that debt
john do you think they went and opened a
credit card and said well i'm going to
pay it off every month
so why everyone who opens the credit
card's like i'll take care of it no one
opens one going i can't wait to go into
debt and carry a balance every month you
know what i really want to do
shackle my family and all of our future
dreams that sounds awesome it's a good
time that's right and here's the thing
in a perfect world where there was no
sin there was no fall of man we could
probably use credit cards responsibly
john james george is getting existential
we live in a fallen world and humans are
fallible creatures and we have the best
intentions don't we john i'm going to
work out three times this week i
actually did but it's cool i forgot the
bachelor was on so i gotta miss this
workout right i'm just saying there's so
many great intentions we have as a
society
and then what happens life hits us right
i thought i could make the payment and
then i couldn't and then this happened
and this happened so i had to get a
personal loan and so then i had to get
the car loan and it's just right to
borrow my roommate and then all of a
sudden my friendship's kind of wonky
right this exact thing that exact advice
when i was in college
i had a credit card and actually i i
would pay it off every month paid off
every month paid off every month
and then my transmission fell out of my
88 tercel easy hatchback right and
big shocker right
and i didn't have it that month and so i
was like i'll make it up i'll make it up
years went by before i made it up right
and it took one thing that happened one
thing that caught me right let me hit
you with some stats in the face i prefer
you don't hit me but
i i couldn't if i wanted to americans
total credit card balance today stands
at 856 billion dollars with a b
every single one of those people said
i'm going to pay it off every month
let me hit you another one national
average car debt among card holders with
unpaid balances over 6 500
americans carried a balance on 52
percent of all active credit card
accounts in the third quarter of 2021.
so they're just handing money over to
massive banking institutions so one out
of two people who had great intentions
are carrying a balance and a large one
at that and for all credit cards here's
the average apr the interest rate on
these things is almost 16 right now oh
my gosh and so here's the thing she's
saying well i can get two percent
or you could pay 16 on that money
which counteracts every little bit of
every penny that you got towards your
flight points which by the way who knows
what 200 000
points are worth they do that on purpose
so that it's confusing and you think
you're rich and then you go try to book
a flight and i go sorry you need a
hundred thousand more points
you can buy those for another four
hundred dollars though
and so on top of that there's the credit
score argument you got to build your
score
right john to eat to breathe to to get
married you got to have that credit
score to be a respectable american adult
you better have a good credit score
right
and as someone who didn't have a credit
score for a long time i just paid off my
mortgage it will fall away soon after i
got a mortgage without a credit score
i've rented cars without a credit score
i've rented apartments multiple without
a credit score houses without a credit
score and so this idea that we've
convinced our children that you need to
get a credit card early to build your
credit score to go into debt so you can
build a score to go into more debt is
the reason we are almost a trillion
dollars in credit card debt just just
credit card debt not just
mortgage debt car debt student loan debt
it was it was two big shockers one is
our friend anthony o'neil when he went
called up all of those apartment
complexes and just said hey i have no uh
no credit score can i still run an
apartment they're like yeah of course
you can ten of them 10 out of 10 right
and then the other one was
if you got a million dollars tomorrow
your credit score would stay at zero
it has no
no relation to how much wealth you have
to how you handle money it's not money
management it's debt debt management
that's right so on top of that if there
wasn't enough john here's the thing if
you pay off your credit card every month
and you're a good little boy or good
little girl
you end up with zero dollars oh
right that's not a cash flow plan that
works no they give you uh two percent
cash back that's right i'm going to get
rich and i've done the math on that john
in our fine print episode you know i
like to do math we did one on the true
cost of credit card rewards and i did
the math on here's what it would take
you would have to spend 25 30 000 to get
a few hundred dollars back
i hope it sounds so good when it says
cash back so you're after i'm winning
money that you're spending buying things
you already would have bought right
that's always the argument i'm only
buying things that i budgeted for right
and we know that the psychology of that
debt is not true you spend more money
when you're using plastic you spend more
money when you're clicking on when it's
someone else's internet that's exactly
right when i'm exchanging cash yep so
there's a lot going on here on top of
all of that hit me baby one more time on
top of all that john here's the part
that people don't think about when you
get the cash back
it's usually on the backs of the people
who couldn't afford it
that's the one that haunts me as a
citizen as a neighbor
that
i get my lower rate because somebody
else is struggling to pay their life
someone else got screwed that's exactly
right how do you like your flight now
and i'm participating in a system that's
hurting people enjoy your free vacation
guys
wow all right stay off a tick tock for
now john furrier forever maybe forever
we'll get on there john we'll we'll
change the world forever one tick tock
no more dances